now the coating solution is fantastic
for a single file but practical usage
fails once we want to load a suite of
files we effectively need to specify a
callback for each one of them instead we
should add support to our asset manager
to allow us to pass a list of files to
load and receive one call back once
they've all been loaded so what we'd
like you to do is modify the load assets
function to take in a list of asset
names and a single callback function now
just as a heads up this process may be a
little bit tricky you'll probably want
to do something right here in the onload
function to keep track of how many files
have been loaded so far make note of it
so that you only have to issue one
callback function one other interesting
aspect that you're going to have to
change is what if all of the assets are
loaded or what if some sub-portion of
them are loaded and other ones need to
be loaded in this situation make sure
you also take into account what happens
if half of the images are loaded or none
of the images that are loaded or all of
the images of loaded in these three
different scenarios you should have a
different logic path on when the
callback function actually gets issued
so for example if all of the assets are
loaded you may only need to do one
callback function immediately